kid circuit is a fashion brand that
creates amazing interactive fashion we
design garments that make magical things
and allow the wearer to express
themselves in new ways I'm Francesca
Rosella and I'm chief creative director
and co-founder of kids circuit basically
how it should circuit garment works is
there is a kiss software running on the
intel power tablet that is sending
messages to the garment to say now you
have to change and display this video or
now change and display this other color
when we start to project usually we
start like from a dream and then we wake
up and say oh let's see if we can make
that happen so we just start designing
the garments like a sort of a normal
fashion design process and then we
create the technology to be perfectly
seamlessly integrated into the garment
one of the best ways to continuously
innovate is like to create the next
technology not just waiting for it to
happen to be on the market and then use
it but just start like your own process
through the tablets you can get your
friends to interact with it you can get
these really strong emotional
connections with your friends that are
far away but at the same time they can
still be with you because they're on you
because they are on your garment but
you're still together because you're
playing together and I think this aspect
of playfulness I think is very strong
within our garments that's really how
the future should be
you